sie ist okay wir machen das jetzt so
asterix und obelix mäßige ziel das jahr
2020 deutschland und die welt drehen
komplett am rad menschen links und
rechts verliehen quasi den verstand
drehen durch und verhalten sich alle
komplett anders als sonst
alle nein ein youtube kanal ein
gallisches dorf quasi gibt es da draußen
was genau so weiter macht wie bisher
und dieses gallische dorf heißt rebecca
ding leute in zeiten wo sich alles um
unseren verändert schauen wir doch mal
auf die dinge die immer noch gleich sind
und einen der größten konstanten
dergleichen dinge in deutschland ist die
geistige verwirrung von mckinsey hat
sich vor kurzem um drei uhr nachts mit
einem disney katerna sich elsa im wald
getroffen wird schon jetzt mal rein und
guck mal was es damit auf sich hat ich
will nicht raus mich kriegen keine zehn
pferde raus aber ich glaube dass unsere
einzige möglichkeit okay leute hier sind
sehr gut bekannte junge dame youtube
rebecca ring in einem zustand der akuten
geistigen verwirrung leute es ist
wirklich ist es ein ernster fall ja wir
sehen ja einen menschen der tatsächlich
an den rande seiner mentalen
tragfähigkeit gebracht ist wodurch
wissen wir nicht genau aber es ist so
leute dass sie halluziniert sie
halluziniert sehr verfolgungswahn
paranoia und denkt dass in ihrem haus
einen disney charaktere eingebrochen ist
und sieht sich jetzt gezwungen das haus
zu verlassen
was will wie ich verstehe ihren auftrag
nicht ich verstehe es einfach nicht so
scheint wirklich sauer auf mich zu sein
und strom gibt einfach immer um mich es
geht einfach nicht 3 wird es vor augen
wir haben ja eine junge dame die
tatsächlich sie leidet defekte leitung
der verfolgungswahn
also wenn man jetzt nicht nur wegen
zuschauer ist und die ganze story
verfolgt und sich gedanken höher als
normal
sie wird von disney charakteren verfolgt
und er ist ganz klar würde man sich
denken was würde man sich denken wenn
ich meinem vater dieses video zeigen
würde er würde ich das anstellen will
sich denken alter die frau ist geistig
verwirrt
und sie hat ihre stromrechnung nicht
bezahlt die ganze verwirrung darüber
dass sie von einem disney charaktere
erfolg wird geht so weit dass sie ihre
stromrechnung nicht mehr gezahlt hat
deswegen hat sie keinen strom mehr
und jetzt denkt sie muss raus im wald
gehen um besagten der caritas zu treffen
ich mein wenn sie hier schon dann kann
ich auch gleich in den park ich gehe nur
kurz drauf schaut vorne im park wo noch
ein bisschen nicht durchkommt mit
taschenlampe mit das ist ein geiles
spiel heute für mich stellt euch vor
dieses video wäre nicht das video von
einer erfolgreichen deutschen youtube
mit 1,9 millionen abonnenten sondern
dass wir einfach so wieder was von der
person hochgeladen wird
ich stelle mir vor was würde man sich da
denken wir geben der ganzen sache so ein
glaubhaftigkeits vorstoß weil es eben
von einer großen youtuber gekommen aber
würde dieses video von irgendwelchen
personen kommt der wird uns denken so
groß ich denke jetzt wahrscheinlich so
ok ich werde sie auf ansprechen und sie
fragen aber ich glaube ich werde mich
sprachlos sein wenn ich sie in so einer
situation da war es einfach gar nicht
mehr was du machen sollst leute ihr
wisst einfach nicht wie das ist
dramatische musik bitte schnitt leute
ihr wisst einfach nicht wie es ist ihren
normalen menschen da draußen könnte ich
gar nicht könnt ich kann nicht
vorstellen wie das essen so einer
situation zu leben damit umzugehen
ihr wisst gar nicht wie das ist wenn man
unter verfolgungswahn von zeichentrick
charakteren leidet die ganze zeit in
meinem kopf nur die frozen himmel
ja haltet auf jeden fall die augen offen
leute und falls sie irgendwas seht was
ich übersehen
der schreibt unbedingt und in die
kommentare leute haltet die augen offen
halten unbedingt bitte die augen offen
alle meine zuschauer diese diese bitter
nötig sie gerade richtig dass die augen
aufhalten soll ist hat nichts damit zu
tun dass ich mehr kommentare auf meinem
video haben nein es geht darum dass ihr
mich schützen könnt weil ich unter einer
akuten bedrohung von einem mädchen mit
blauen kleid und wandten zopf leider ok
bitte haltet ausschau nach ihren meinen
videos und dann schreibt mir in die
kommentare
die ich dann drei tage nachdem ich im
wald war lese macht das um mich zu
schützen
genau ich weiß nicht ob ich gerade eine
dunkle gestalt gesehen habt hat hinten
aber es ist echt gruselig und ich will
mich nicht umdrehen
das war echt gerade co machine wo ist
die grenze ich werde meine erste frage
an euch wo ist die grenze bei der ganzen
sache okay
wo ist die grenze an der wir als
zuschauer als kritischer zuschauer
geneigt sagen kann
okay die bkw hat jetzt von roll play für
ihr video die grenze überschritten hinzu
ich glaube dass wirklich und sie ist
lost mental würden wir es erkennen
würden wir die grenze erkennen wo der
punkt erreicht ist wo sie quasi ihre
alge videos ernste und komplett
abdriftet ich glaube das nicht merken
der tauchte gerade einfach wissen nichts
auf leute ich fahre ich nicht
becker verstand nicht die leute wild die
ernsthaft denken dass wir bäcker euch
verarschen würde erstmal kurze dollar
komplett schwarz angezogen
das macht die situation kraft mich
besser ehrlicher sich täglich durch
er ist gleich nicht jetzt leute
sie dreht noch nicht noch nicht erst
gleich sie dreht leicht durch wenn es so
weiter gehen weil jetzt gerade ist sie
noch voll im vollen besitz ihrer
geistigen kräfte und das voll auf der
höhe
wenn sie sie macht ja normale sachen
gucken wir mal was ich auf dem handy
gesehen habe als ihr über facetime
angerufen ach so agiert über fest
ich bin manchmal so vergesslich bringt
das manchmal müsse man welcher welche
disney charaktere mit aktive
zeichentrick charaktere schon für
facetime angerufen hatte ich könnte
jetzt gar nicht mehr sagen ob micky maus
zum beispiel ein gerufen hat oder
spongebob sicht ich glaube es
fortschritte
wir haben wir diesen schon facetime
freundin balkan spongebob und er ist
sich irgendwie herunter gelaufen
aber seht ich dass sie dunkel das hier
ist
wo seht ihr das nicht ich kann ich bin
ich bin die siebenjährige grundschülerin
ich hab' ich kann nicht erkennen wie
düster ist heute mal andere ernst
gemeinte frage wann ist eigentlich der
punkt erreicht wo diese videos zu drehen
auch so ein bisschen sonne sondern
gefährdung für die allgemeinheit dar
schließlich eine gefährdung aber so eine
beeinträchtigung der lebensqualität bei
anderen menschen gleich mal vor ihr seid
irgendwie sondern junger menschen die
junge frau so und die jobs irgendwie
nachttischen parks und dann seht ihr
dann euren taschenlampen kegel der durch
den park wird und die hört seine stimme
die so in seiner zittrigen ängstlichen
lage mit sich selbst redet die gal
also ich weiß wie es euch geht auch
meine oma bilder die den schreck ihres
lebens bekommen die leute ich gehe
zurück ich gehe der anderen weg jetzt
und dann gucke ich noch ein bisschen auf
dem spielplatz und das war's dann gehe
ich mich was irgendwie keine ahnung sehe
ich hier keine eltern vor allem ich lese
garantierten sich inzwischen komplett
ausgestattet die sich im wald mit elsa
treffen wollte oder dass man sich
niemals im wald mitesser treffen sollte
ach genau weil die beschreibung wieder
wird wichtig beschreibung der blick in
dem schreiben verrät uns mache es nicht
mit freunden freund freundin bruder
schwester oder machbar
ganz wichtig vor allem nicht mit dem
nacht ich weiß alle von euch da draußen
dachten sich geil quarantäne
jetzt könnte ich doch mal mit meinem
nachbarn den disney prinzessin jagen da
und dort
mit rassismus
dies ist eine schneeflocke aus papier
ausgeschnitten und sie so der bastelkurs
der grundschule war hier scheiße ich bin
raus das ist nach rheda mit der
schneeflocke hier sieht das einfach es
ist einfach geisteskrankheit es ist es
ist wirklich eine schneeflocke unsere
schlimmsten befürchtungen haben sich
bewahrheitet es ist eine schneeflocke
und dieses schneeflocke ist ich krieg
wirklich gänse wirklich gern sagt wenn
ich sagen muss die schneeflocke ist
nicht mal die ist nicht mal aus papier
leute dieses plastik
die wissen da drauf packt ihr wisst ihr
gerade macht leute ich ich checke ist
nämlich weil ich vor kurzem mal als als
loyaler wickie fans natürlich auch mal
gezeigt hat was sie so macht und habe
ich gesehen dass die neuen merge haus
bringen und jetzt nutzt sie dieses video
geschickt ja man kann nämlich auch
beides gleichzeitig machen
man kann einerseits grundschülern angst
einjagen man kann aber gleichzeitig auch
grundschülern merge verkaufen
das geht wir sind in erster linie der
besteuerung mein limitierter lebten zeit
weil er zeitlich begrenzt nochmal hinter
limitierte zugeschrieben damit auch die
grundschule fraktion versteht das ist
jetzt einer von ihrem merge pullis und
dem platz ist hier so ganz geschickt in
dem video
sie sagen sie ist ja heute gut ab
jetzt wird's ernst jetzt nein nein nein
es ist nicht so spannend dass ich muss
sagen ich finde es noch okay wenn du mir
grundschüler angst damit ein jagst dass
irgendwelche disney charaktere böse
zauberkräfte haben das finde ich ok ich
finds auch okay wenn du diese angst
nutzt um ihr merchandise zu verkaufen
aber das geht zu weit
[Musik]
das denn passieren
wer diese frau so las der puppe okay
der blick in den kommentare zeigt uns
auch wie sie ihre geisteskranke masche
wir jetzt weitermachen will und zwar ist
von ihr selbst ein angeblicher kommentar
da denn nur lautet aufschneiden oder
nicht aufschneiden
na ja so oder so würde ich fand es schön
zu sehen dass auch wenn alle um uns drum
herum komplett durchdrehen ist noch ein
paar sachen gibt die gleich bleibende
kriegt ihr darüber einfach ich
vorgeschlagen klar bin ich bin an dieser
stelle raus ich küsse augen wollte
bleibt gesund bleibt bauernfamilien
zschau